wir schauen in die Ukraine die schnellen
Vorstöße ukrainischer Truppen in den
vergangenen Tagen sorgen für
vorsichtigen Optimismus auch bei der
US-Regierung die von einer Verschiebung
einer Momentum der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte spricht die russischen
Truppen hätten ihre Kampfposition
verlassen und ihre Vorräte
zurückgelassen die Front hat sich
verschoben wir schauen mal auf die Karte
und an die neue Front nach kubianski ist
unser Reporter Paul ronsheimer mit
seinem Team Gefahren hier ist ein
Bericht
wir fahren hinein in die umkämpfte Stadt
cobiansk eine Stadt die geteilt ist
durch einen Fluss und jetzt auch durch
den Frontverlauf auf der einen Seite des
Flusses stehen noch immer die Russen die
andere Seite ist bereits durch die
ukrainische Armee befreit worden es
zeigt sich immer wieder das gleiche Bild
Zerstörung und russische Propaganda wo
man auch hinschaut hinter mir sieht man
einen Plakat der Russen die sagen
Ukraine und Russen das sind die gleichen
Leute und die Russen kämpfen hier weiter
ungefähr drei Kilometer entfernt auf der
Seite das russische Plakat ist schnell
durch ukrainische Soldaten entfernt
anders diese Hinterlassenschaften sie
werden schwerer zur entsorgen sein
Handgranaten auf dem Tisch im ehemaligen
Hauptquartier der Russen in der
ukrainischen Polizeistation die Sie auch
bald wieder sein soll
dass die russische Flagge immer noch zu
sehen und die russischen Zeichen wir
können ja nicht wirklich weit gehen denn
alles in diesem Gebiet ist noch vermiet
die Versorgungslage in kobiansk ist
schlecht die Menschen sind auf der Suche
nach Nahrung stehen hier für Medikamente
an die Strom- und Wasserversorgung ist
unterbrochen die Menschen laden ihre
Handys an Generatoren auf nicht zur
Kommunikation sondern mal ein bisschen
Licht in der Nacht zu haben dann wenn
die Kämpfer am intensivsten sind
[Musik]
die Menschen hier hoffen nun dass sich
die jüngsten Erfolge der Ukraine
ausweiten vielleicht sogar zu einer
umfassenden Gegenoffensive und das noch
bevor der Winter kommt
wir nehmen jetzt zu Paul ronsheimer Paul
wie berechtigt sind diese Hoffnungen auf
weitere offensiven noch vor dem Winter
womöglich
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass die
ukrainische Armee in dem gleichen Umfang
weitermachen kann wie sie es jetzt
geschafft hat das ist ein sehr sehr
großes Gebiet das ist zweimal London
einmal Zypern das ist riesig wenn man
sich das anschaut aber dass die Ukraine
insbesondere ohne immense weitere Waffen
Unterstützung ohne Kampfpanzer aus dem
Westen hier weitere Gebiete erobern
können und zwar schnell das halte ich
doch für sehr fraglich denn insbesondere
im Süden und in luchansk und Donez
Regionen also das was auch früher schon
posische Separatisten kontrolliert haben
diese Regionen sind doch besser
gefestigt also es wird definitiv
schwieriger für die Ukraine aber man
merkt wenn man dort an der Front ist
dass der Wille der ukrainischen Soldaten
alles zurück zu erobern immens ist
erzähl uns auch von den Menschen die du
getroffen hast dort
die Menschen sind einerseits glücklich
weinen vor Freude wir haben dort einen
im Ehepaar interviewt auch vor diesem
Plakat dass ihr gesehen habt die uns
erzählten dass die Leute die für die
Ukraine waren gequält wurden dass die
gefoltert wurden dass sie dort teilweise
verschleppt wurden und gleichzeitig
erlebt man gerade in kubian ist das dort
noch immer Krieg herrscht Artillerie
vorher als wir dort dieses Interview
geführt haben und dann wieder schnell
weg mussten also der Terror ist noch
lange nicht zu Ende auch wenn bestimmte
Gebiete befreit sind geht dieser Krieg
weiter und die Sorge der Menschen ist
dass ihre Lage weiterhin so schlimm
bleibt weil die Russen versuchen würden
weiter anzugreifen mit Artillerie oder
zurück zu erobern und das bedeutet
natürlich vor allem für die Zivilisten
eine dramatische Lage weiterhin keinen
Strom kein Wasser all das was wir dort
auch heute gesehen haben die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen kommt wieder zu Besuch nach Kiew
was ist von diesem Besuch zu erwarten
große Unterstützung Ursula von der Leyen
gilt als Freundin der Ukraine sie war
relativ am Anfang des Krieges hier
silensky hat sie mit überschwänglichen
Worten gelobt und sie wird mit selensky
natürlich auch über Waffen Unterstützung
sprechen das kann sie nicht entscheiden
aber sie hat natürlich die Möglichkeit
die Regierungschefs an einen Tisch zu
bekommen also das wird das entscheidende
Thema sein Unternehmen natürlich die
gasfrage und die finanzielle
Unterstützung und dann für silenski
ebenfalls ein wichtiges Thema die
eu-beitrittsperspektive denn die ist ja
eröffnet worden
vielen Dank
[Musik]